what is the full spectrum of what aliens
might look like to us
now that we've laid this all on
on the table of like all right so there
has to be some overlap and this
uh causal chain that led to them
what are we what are we looking for what
do you think we should be looking for so
you met you mentioned mass spec
measuring certain objects that aliens
could create or are aliens themselves um
we show up to a planet or maybe not a
planet or maybe what what the what the
hell is the basic object we're trying to
show ourselves assembly index of let's
cut ourselves a break let's assume that
they are
they they're metabolized they've got an
energy source and they're they've
there are a size that we can recognize
let's give our cut ourselves a break
because it could be aliens that are so
big we don't recognize we're seeing them
there might be aliens that are so small
we don't yet have the ability to you
know we have microscopes i can see you
know far enough away that just wouldn't
be i see them so that's a good range so
let's just make a range let's just be
very am pro-centric and say we're going
to look for aliens roughly our size and
technology our size because we we know
it's possible on earth right i mean a
reasonable thing to do would be to to
find exoplanets that in the same zone as
earth in terms of heat and stuff
and then say
hey if there's that same kind of gravity
same kind of stuff we could reasonably
assume
that the alien life there might use a
similar kind of physical infrastructure
and then we're good so then then you'll
then then your question becomes really
relevant so right let's use vision sound
touch
and so okay that's really nice so the if
there's a lot of aliens out there
there's a good likelihood if you match
to the planet that they're going to be
in the same spatial and temporal
operating in the same spatial temporal
domain as humans okay within that
what
wha
what did they look like
visually what do they sound like
uh what are they oh god this sounds
creepy tastes like
what is it
oh it smells like smell like that sounds
like our clubhouse and he's like can we
have sex with aliens which was basically
me saying
but it wasn't actually about sex it was
about is our chemistry compatible right
is there some yeah yeah yeah can can we
um yeah
are they edible too they could be very
edible they could be delicious that's
why i want to see some aliens right
because i think are there
i think evolution
um
i mean evolution exploits symmetry right
because why why generate memory why
generate storage the need for storage
space when you can use symmetry
so
and symmetry is quite maybe quite
effective in allowing you to
mechanically design stuff right
so maybe alien it could you could be
reasonable to assume that aliens could
have
they could be bipedal they could be
symmetric in the same way
they might have a couple of eyes or a
couple of sensors we can make make that
and perhaps there's this whole zoo of
different aliens out there and we'll
never get to be able to classify some of
the weird aliens we can't interact with
because they have made such weird stuff
yeah but we are just going to look at
we're going to find aliens that look
most like us why not
because those are the first ones we're
likely to see yeah
yeah but i i think it's really hard to
imagine what the space of aliens is
because the space is huge because you
know like one of the arguments that you
can make about wildlife emerges in
chemistry is because chemistry is the
first
scale in terms of like you know building
up objects from elementary objects um
that the number of possible things that
could exist is larger than the universe
can possibly make all at once right so
um
so you imagine you have two planets and
they're cooking some geochemistry you
know our planet invented one kind of
biochemistry and presumably as you start
building up the complexity of the
molecules the chances of the overlap in
those trajectories those causal chains
being built up is probably very low um
and it gets lower and lower as it gets
further advanced along its evolutionary
path so i think it's very difficult to
imagine predicting the technologies that
aliens are going to have
i mean it's it's so it's you're looking
at basically planets have kind of
convergent chemistry but there's some
variability and then you're looking
basically at the outgrowth into the
possibility space chemistry
you